[Applause]
I don't know what I did hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to to
chill now this is a point-and-click
adventure game that's supposed to be a
little surreal and more than a little
weird and I'm not 100% sure what I'm
supposed to do you know I think I'm
happy for the both of us is that
happened that happened
okay
[Music]
okay alright well alright okay then so
this is how the oh my god this game is
freaking adorable this game is freaking
adorable oh you cute little bastards you
oh you little singsong pieces of [ __ ]
okay alright you pour water on this
[ __ ] yeah that's horrible if it's
this is legitimately horrible why would
you do that my split the combo something
here didn't play well okay well this guy
seems to be immune to a lot about well
you know that's supposed to be a hint
because I was pretty sure I already knew
about that I'm sorry that's not good
wait
that bird somehow get drunk on wall all
righty then good morning sunshine how
you doing beautiful ready to greet the
day I suppose okay oh no it's like the
beginning of Donkey Kong someone's
stealing your banana hoard oh okay all
right I think I know the crux ooh that's
[Applause]
never mind that it's not like Donkey
Kong
you're just being kidnapped like
Princess Peach oh we're nowhere we're in
the void between worlds oh it's easy as
one-two-three get you to me what if I go
the other way
is that how we do this oh I can figure
it out I'm smart and full brains you're
full beans don't even think about it
buddy
okay all right I'm just gonna oh oh you
think oh you think
okay easy enough guy you bits
Oh what you gonna do now I guess I'm a
thrust thrust my crotch towards you oh
come on big monkey man in the sky stop
being such a douche I don't even know
what you're doing to me I don't even
know what I am if you're a monkey man
what the hell am i yeah I'm a markiplier
but that doesn't matter
I don't know if I'm ever gonna be able
to get this goddamn cherry somehow I
gotta turn this into the giving tree and
chop it all right let's try this one yes
magic wow that worked out amazingly well
I can't be nearly as smart as I think I
am because things just don't work out
for me and you bastard don't even think
about it please
Oh
Churchill oh it's a title screen oh
that's freaking adorable
oh I love that so much
choo choo you so strong choo choo you so
strong oh this game is just delightful
oh that's cool all right never mind this
game is horrifying and horrible because
the physics is that the anatomical
improbabilities what's going on that
guy's head is just not okay markiplier
that's gone choo choo here don't know
where that came you know in any other
circumstance I think I'd be happy about
getting a free pinwheel but at this
point I just don't want to know where it
was all right how about we climb you
okay I can do it to a tree but somehow I
can't do it - this dude's giant dome
alright how about you or you go up there
buddy I'm so incredibly intelligent
right now it though don't pull on that
you have no idea what that's gonna do is
[Applause]
[Music]
that some kind of infection what the
hell
oh sweet moves there buddy
alright let me try to get back up there
and maybe I can do something else
besides pull on the cord there no nah oh
well there I go again apparently can I
have another friend wheel gal what kind
of horrible reality is that is now that
I said before come on you got to be able
to help me out man come on please it's a
cherry it's this big give me my cherry
that's inside of you
I don't think there's any hope - this
was a mean what does that mean did I get
an achievement achievement come on
please please there's gotta be one more
one more sweet chance please no we loop
back to the beginning okay so there's no
chance that he's gonna just give it to
me but maybe there's a chance that I can
get up there you can do this try this
one last time give me one I want buddy
here's my money oh that's horrible
all right you try talking again I don't
understand what happened there I guess I
scared you all right okay sorry little
buddy please please just talk some sense
into this guy
no fine there's gotta be one thing I can
do come on well [ __ ] one more time okay
I'm sorry
what does this do
No I feel like I'm on some bizarre kids
show you know one of those ones that
when you look at it as an adult it seems
a lot scarier than it should have been
hmm oh poor choo-choo
are you just not strong enough with
those straight oh you're is that gonna
be oh I thought that was gonna be
incredibly useful to me No well I'm
completely out of ideas and there's
nothing else that I could possibly do to
sit whoa I don't know what you're
talking about but I'm assuming it's a G
oh okay well this is a terrible plan
Thanks thank you for that all right well
now I got it got a sign thanks for
cleaning up I guess it turn you now
maybe maybe not okay hello I'm sorry man
I don't know what this guy's possibly
thinking what you chose doing all this
[ __ ] around him this is no reason
for this secret exists oh well I guess
there we go then now I use that as an ax
or a hammer to bash your head in and
then yep here we go oh never mind then I
thought I was gonna cave your head in
like a barbarian ah perfect
yes okay hang on let's try this and now
let's jump off of this onto this bad boy
there we go
wasn't this so hard Jesus you big yellow
[ __ ] try to put me through all this
[ __ ] with your stupid bat Edie
nevermind number one I hate it I hate
everything about it
I hate literally everything about that
oh that is the worst thing I've ever
seen in my life there's not enough
bleach that I could drink to make that
image go away oh my god boy what's
happening now why are we losing it again
and where is it gonna be lost I already
hate you I already hate you already I
feel it's time just wait come on man
we've got this okay all right come on
it's right there come on all right fine
you do something can I throw you at it
whoops inside of that okay there's gotta
be something else that you do right all
right well that guy's gone forever now
so it's only me I jump on you Oh smart
Oh not smart that's not how physics work
oh come on I went to engineering school
I may not be a full engineer but I know
and physics is [ __ ] there we go easy
easy easy
[Music]
there doesn't make any sense at all in
what kind of reality would you turn into
the Frog that was bad that doesn't make
it I don't like this this is getting
more and more horrifying as the levels
go on I'm sorry I realize this is may
not be just a normal ordinary child's
game where they play a children's stuff
it might actually be something much much
more sinister you look like the bird
from turbo dismount i'm parently riding
you like the book guff
pop-pop we'll get you oh yeah amazing oh
no come on okay oh wow okay well all
right then Zach a booby Oh
oh my goodness gravy oh this is amazing
can I get a gap through thank you thank
you for that I love it
oh it's so colorful and beautiful and
it's such a drug trip no we're upside
down now wow I love the music it's
beautiful but at the same time you know
that video has anybody ever seen that
video where it's like the other video
where it's like this is what English
sounds like - no okay apparently that's
happening it's like this is what English
sounds - non English speakers and that's
all I'm getting from this it's just Sims
language all over again oh no oh you big
sucky bastard all right fine then we're
gonna play like this it's like some
horror game where you can't go too near
the enemies
those are gonna
well oh you got to prove me out move me
out no that makes no sense okay that
makes sense sure all right we'll go that
one no all right
easy peasy - suppose oh and now it's
night great and now darkness falls upon
us here in this wonderful world where we
live and we're so happy and that rock is
not happy all right okay okay all right
okay excuse me sorry your bulbous body
was just too much for me to handle I
bounced right off no it's easy and why
did these aw man this is this is
incredible like this is just an
incredible plethora of what the [ __ ] you
know it's it doesn't make any goddamn
sense but I love it
you know I'm gonna stop questioning and
I'm just going to accept it no no no
don't get absorbed in don't get absorbed
into the big body please tell me that's
not gonna happen
okay that's better than what I thought
was gonna happen I thought it was gonna
be like a Magic School Bus episode where
they got to go through Arnold's a noose
or well we're alive I think if anything
in this universe can be called life me
first
yeah at some point you got it admit
this was my cherry I kind of like pulled
it out of my ass in the beginning of
this game and I think that you just okay
[Music]
alright sure yeah that makes total sense
I love it alright anything else game
does alright what do you got for me mr.
snail man hey can you help me with the
weird holes in the hall ceiling
you know the halls Ealing neither of
these are options that I enjoy very much
to be perfectly honest no I changed my
mind I kind of want Tetris now but again
I'm not on two percent sure why oh boy I
think it's following me so I guess I
gotta go in here yeah yeah yeah that's
right oh you don't even know what to do
hahaha okay I win I'm back to cheol-hun
- chill man
I'm couch man Chimayo oh no oh no okay
well they're coming for me I know that
so I just gotta be on the lookout for
when they're gonna be cornering me it's
probably gonna be extremely okay let's
see what this does
please tell me it does something good Oh
I'll get rekt okay I'm gonna try to go
from the back guy no that's god damn it
damn you BAM got it
you suck if this was a point-based thing
you'd be losing oh come on
oh come on alright I got it
what do you what else does that mean
what do you want from me alright you
sure you got what you came for so what
are you gonna do now oh god what is this
nightmare of a thing oh alright fine
I'll just go for the Churchill's
man I'm quickly realizing that I just do
not like how hairy the sign is I mean I
don't get me wrong I'm starting to fall
in love with to chill here but I don't
think I'm in love with you chills hairy
nature that is just something that I
could do without and with that the hairy
nightmare is hopefully over we done did
I do it that is a space invaders metal
yeah I knew I was playing back man what
who do you think you are me okay well
super glad about that I'm very glad we
did that mr. snail don't
yeahö me
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you for that all right I
guess I'll jump inside your mouth if
you're if you're offering Who am I to
turn on my nose do okay well that's not
oh oh boy I have one I'll take a cupcake
please I'll take that please Wow look at
me how about well this does not seem to
have helped me in any way do I have to
play all the minigames to be able to get
what I need I'm pretty sure that's how
this works right oh no please okay thank
you play some more games then how about
space invaders to chill invaders let's
do a whole lot of that huh ah I don't
like I'll board it up and condemn that
is but I'll I'll do it alright I'm not
the greatest at space invaders but you
know it is what it is that's not good oh
they're horrible I hate them thank you
for nothing
oh that's the worst thing
I don't understand what you're going for
there okay all right well this makes
very little sense all right
again not a hundred percent sure I
understand what you you know I am let's
is there like instructions on this okay
all right well this the worst thing I've
ever seen in my life it's a little
disgusting I will admit but effective I
suppose well alright I'll take it for
what it is that's not good all right
drip on me just give me give me a only a
full load don't like what I'm saying oh
well [ __ ] thanks only got the blood on
me instead of the puke at least I hope
it's puke what dick I never thought I'd
imagine situation where I was hoping
something would be some form of vomit in
a place can you vomit on my head I
really really want it for some reason
this is a desire I have very strong
thank you my sensibilities are quite
lacking in this in this endeavor
thank you for nothing
all right I won I don't feel good about
my victory but I won I've got a lot of
mysterious fluids drenched on my face
and whatnot but that is life I suppose
here in the void oh you're beautiful oh
no please go I guess I'm back to normal
then sorry okay Oh No
Wow okay well that's okay thank you for
that
guess I'll just all right here well no
oh you're teasing me duties and oh
you're teasing me I don't like to be
teased like that all right okay Gaia
okay I see your game okay no oh wait
there we go no come on now give me the
thing that's gonna let me beat you
please oh no you're exploding oh I don't
know oh no your ghost oh that's that's
sad I think I'm not a hundred percent
sure but I think that's sad okay thank
you can I get another can I get one more
please oh I'm really begging and hoping
upon a star for it please please tell me
I care okay whatever this is it's an ice
cream sundae so yeah that would know
when yeah yeah okay I don't know where I
pulled those out of all right the worst
thing about to chill I think is it's a
he's a mash of hair he is literally a
hairball there's no internal nevermind
he's a hair penis
almost almost no
okay thank you well all of these were
incredibly useless to me I'll just do
the weird smiley face again as things
get steadily crazier and I lose my
sanity Mortimer how many times are gonna
learn this don't get near okay Tetris
time I'm ready baby I'm gonna shut your
whole establishment down don't tease me
like oh that's so nice of it all right
what are you gonna do are you gonna do a
buddy oh I'm in a spot I know I am all
right come on do you suck at Tetris or
use something like a good I'm
questioning something a little bit here
[Music]
that's normal I remember that in the
Academy yeah definitely
okay here comes win no not yay good job
you did it we're proud of you okay well
that is daddy something new
oh that's not good I guess I'll hide
okay this isn't done guys you know I'm
pretty much pretty sure I know my
tetanus Tetris tetanus I have tetanus
who's eating rust the other day and well
you know not hugs that's true okay don't
okay all right that's not fair at all oh
oh no oh oh no what does that even mean
are those symbols I don't know what that
means is that some kind of time okay I
did it
apparently I did it with all the skill
inside my head in that know exactly what
I'm doing
hey can I get some food that's gonna
horribly change me make me slightly
girthier various different ways hello
all right I'll take the antacid
apparently what you choose me Oh to
chill it's me I am choo choo hello I'll
take that thank you with my oh these
don't help it all right oh wait no
everyone could make fun of me now I'm
just a big dumb idiot because why else
would I have big strong arms it wasn't
to crank a Yankee here hmm okay all
right I don't know how my hair has
become so strong oh yeah
you ain't nothing to my muscular hair
arms
mwah baby
a little help here buddy just a little
help please just all I'm asking perfect
great oh come on you big giant penis in
the sky no that's not what I wanted this
is not what I wanted oh okay all right
that's the thing that's happening now
we're just good enjoy the dance party ah
a no touch zone so what I'm supposed to
understand from this is if I touch that
I will die and not only will I die I
will die a most horrible death a death
unlike any other because there's some
things that are worse than death such of
living in a perpetual state of torment
between the worlds of death or none
death and that's what'll happen I'll try
that Hey
unleash it my little [ __ ] you listen to
me you little poop stick you don't touch
it hey what did I tell you you little
[ __ ] you stay over there and you don't
touch the damn thing because the signs
are meant to be read well I touched it
that's not good hmm okay all right
cosmologically we seem to be fine
[Music]
we're gonna indianajones this [ __ ]
hahaha all right good job yeah I'm sure
that it's crushed to death by my oh no
no don't like that no just don't like
the veins on my hand this is the worst
thing I said the worst oh boy oh boy
horrible jelly bean fruits Oh No hey
that's discriminatory also what the hell
is happening and why are they slightly
blood-stained
your feet also slightly blood-stained
very concerning that's stupid
okay that's you're just born a racist
okay alright you can't be this beautiful
but also okay hey douche alright fine
I'll go this way
what have you got here hello friend why
are you here I said that with quite a
beat hmm sorry about viola yeah you
heard me right all right got that what
do you want that
yeah okay I'll take back hey I'm not uh
I'm gonna do choke can I get through
uh-huh yeah okay
I'm assuming this is extremely
convincing or some kind of elaborate
mating dance be the way are you
impressed
oh you are thank you so much can I have
the cherry now please can I have the
cherry okay no no I gotta do it for me
first
mm-hmm no it's tasty okay ah this is a
problem no this is a problem I can
already see the eyes a problem problem
you got a problem
Oh problem bigger problem problem oh
okay oh we're all bad
I don't know how I got looped out but
okay
alrighty then what about you okay
Harry warden Odie
okay okay well you have this shove it in
your gob okay that's not what I remember
happening to myself okay all right let's
not do that ever again
thank you I don't need a quiz and I know
that's not how that goes I need a hint I
need to figure out what the hell is
gonna do shut up shut up you stupid
douche shove it in your gob what are you
gonna do you're gonna turn into a
horrible monster see again come on hmm
okay that didn't help nobody what is
that what is it
oh really oh the orange one oh okay I
need to get the orange one because the
orange ones over here and different no I
don't want him to do it I wanted to do
it myself all right whatever
yes I know we can't do it he's a wimp a
weakling now I gotta do it with my wimpy
weakling arms oh yeah I still don't know
how that's gonna help me maybe you can
help me oh I know what you can do you
can help me get the blue fruit can't you
I bet you can get me the blue fruit
please one blue fruit thank you
oh all right that didn't work at all how
about you go over there can you give me
the blue fruit oh all righty then hey
stop being a douche
how about you you guys want a spider
[Music]
wait if you're a spider and I'm a spider
I know exactly what I need to do now you
think you can run away from me and not
let me know exactly what I'm supposed to
do no that's not true all right okay
that is horribly destructive it's at all
come on you big veiny fingered Venus in
the sky come on how many times do I got
to go through this Oh
[Music]
all right that's norm hi hello who are
you and why are you and what are you
supposed to be are you supposed to be
jello please don't eat that you laugh
beautifully can I have that please today
can I have that could I have that please
I'm too chill may I have you don't
depend I don't like the way you speak
okay you're a bit of a prick
all right well I'll just go over here
then screw you it's not worth it oh it's
worth it absolutely anything okay well
you're just a big old piece of [ __ ]
I don't know I said to you but if you
feel pretty insulted about that yeah you
should feel bad oh you're just a giant
prick aren't you that is my personal
property and you are withholding it from
me and that is illegal oh you just had
to do that thing you know I'm gonna
climb in there and get it from you I
don't care if I have to go in through
your mouth or through your pothole I'm
gonna get that cherry that sounds weird
when I shout it out loud like that but
you know what I'm gonna do fine okay
nevermind then if you could stop
resonating like a vocoder I'd be very
happy about it I know what I'm doing and
I do it I know which is best wha
hello I'm inside you now what are you
gonna do about it huh nothing to choke
oh okay all right well this is
okay that's not that can't be
comfortable for you sir or ma'am that
can't be comfortable
ah speaking of uncomfortable alright
hello hello how are you okay I don't
know why you're okay you just ate my
friend rat I'm going to kill you
smack come on oh man just not the
strength for murder huh oh that doesn't
make any sense forward point oh boy
Oh point murder murder yes delightful
delightful oh boy
okay well that still didn't help I think
I still have to crack you open which is
just a terrible thought but here we go
smack smoke smoke alright sorry
none of the king's men are gonna be able
to put you back together again that
doesn't make any sense how did an egg
Koff up an entire fried egg that makes
the least amount of sense I've ever seen
in my entire life long-long okay you're
dead now Oh even less sense that okay I
uh I do you have nipples why do you have
nipples where do you have nipples
ah perfect a nice hat with a stitch in
it Wow
oh come on don't get greedy he's just
got the cherry back oh okay oh my god I
thought you were just a ball of hair but
what is that on your insides are those
your organs oh that's that's all right
okay all right this this game is bizarre
oh no my hat
oh no I'm my acorn hat that I thought
was my hair but then I guess I am all
here so it doesn't matter doing
that's not my hat oh come on no how many
got in there
what is it tf2 in there is that a condom
hat that is very clearly a common pad in
the background by in the foreground up
there okay can you stop that please
that's very rude oh I'm sorry what we
plant and birds here
oh sorry I didn't realize okay never
mind I'm gonna try that again okay all
right we're gonna try this again
boink nope that didn't do anything
all right try one more time here it's
better actually be physics-based
Wow okay all right then
no I know what I need to do you shut up
we're gonna go high-angle whoa yeah yeah
buddy
haha I know what I need to do now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoopsies Bad's now what I wanted to do
so I guess I gotta try to help come on a
third oh this is the trick is like the
strangest okay so that's where you're
gonna be huh I think what I gotta do is
I gotta yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
there we go yeah that's the good stuff
oh yeah that's it yeah that's what you
get for trying to wait so I'm totally
just ripped to yourself apart tore you
inside okay well very all right good I
think I don't really know but I think
it's good oh no where are we now seem to
be stopping to chill hate you to shut up
oh god the bowling ball - that doesn't
work out nup nup the screen up boxing
glove
number one trophy Oh cheering perfect
just bite down already and eat the
cherry bitten all you're just gonna pour
it on the head and make out it later
okay well one more of a good ring Oh
[Music]
nope he's not dead boys thought that he
was gonna die but no oh yeah okay now
he's dead he's very dead ah Rock'em
Sock'em robots okay I'm assuming anyway
not a hard person sure how this works oh
I don't know I don't know how to punch
I'm not herbes and sure how to punch how
do i wha bah bah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bad pop back
all right BAPS you good huh you will go
for another round huh oh come on
second hoop you think you'd take me even
though I got scrawny arms I got better
reach baby okay never mind
throw it over I don't go down without a
fight this is like youtubers boxing
isn't it huh feisty feisty baby huh
feisty baby that's right that's right
that's right keep your knock blocked off
but whatever I said whatever you get
your block knocked oh oh oh you just
hate each other oh my god oh I'm very
sorry about that oh I'm gonna incredibly
impressed at your to agility but calm
down I love the animation in this game
the anime is adorable it's super cute I
know go claim your prize and then
probably lose it it's like a cartoon
show you know Riley I cook Riley I
coyote wily coyote is never gonna kiss
the road around Jerry this is not gonna
happen the only way to win is to know
okay you never mind
[Music]
did I just see like a skeletal man made
out of wood no he's dead now I have no
idea what happened in the mean time but
I'm pretty sure choo-choo screwed up
something bad
[Music]
Oh wonderful horrible no please don't no
please
oh no don't all right well well done
everybody
you really uh God you really suck uh oh
yeah that's not right
now this is scooby-doo scene man if I
was taking LSD this would make a lot of
sense to chill again I guess this is
horrible
I mean when you really think about it on
a base level this is insane and horrible
it's horrible and insane oh no how we
gonna get locked out of this now could
blink ah nope that's not how knobs
working I don't know why you even
thought that was your first instinct
okay ah excellent looks great on you oh
please dude I don't know what's at me
okay that made even less sense than
whatever happened before
[Music]
hey I hate it I know don't lick that ya
know jus okay now I actually have taken
a magic mushroom that's all right okay
why let's try to grab the spiky cherry
that's gonna work out real good for you
Oh blowing on it help that doesn't even
make any sense
throw it Adam
all right I'll talk to you okay all
right good conversation that we had here
I'm talking to a cactus expecting that
it would talk back I guess I am a
talking furball so will be the
difference in asleep okay calm down
there yeah all right then all right this
doesn't help anybody here what is this
big red button do absolutely dick did
okay how about the other hats oh okay
are you lick that why would you lick
that don't even try okay I never liked
that nor want any more of that horrible
it's new home and also it looks like
you're some horrible amalgamation of
city streets weeping snow it is awful
good I have it can I have that evil
snowman all right sure
yeah I've been blatant uh horror games
to know when I can beat something and
I'm pretty sure I can beat you dude now
have your head
all right fine then geez I don't know
your problem oh okay what is the clue ah
it's back in the normal world Rui Rui
Rui Rui ride ride ride ride ride
let me just soak in some sweet summer
water
not a hundred percent sure why I did
that
oh no I got a Peru bland maybe I need to
pee on the Snowman that seems about
right right yeah can I pee yep okay I
can pee I can legitimately just piss on
a snowman
excuse me you don't mind do you you
don't mind do you
I'm very sorry actually I'm not at all
sorry all right so I gotta find
something better to pee on is that what
you're saying
you can't be a peon right that's
horrible
oh it's horrible okay okay here we go
again
[Music]
there was no point in that but wait did
that have another effect on anything
else in this world because those are all
the same right so if that group over
here okay but what did that do to the
that do to the radio it did nothing to
the radio okay not your favorite choices
but alright okay sure I'll go with that
one so is there anything else that I
need to piss on because I'm pretty sure
that I'm ready to piss on more stuff
yes okay I guess I'm not pissing on
anything else whoa whoa yes Wow
okay but that's good progress right that
means that does that mean that in the
normal world that's out and about hell
yeah
[Music]
well done me oh come on let me have a
little bit of victory let me have just
one minute of victory before you start
screwing okay I'm sorry
oh no yeah this is my eternal struggle
this is horrible
come back please whack-a-mole do I
really get to whack-a-mole I hope I get
to whack-a-mole I'm ready let me walk
please please let me walk
I just want to whack oh please Wow okay
not me let me whack the mole okay laughs
okay too slow ah I'm gonna get you you
think you're gonna get away from me huh
oh this seems to be a problem okay well
who's shootin what that's not right I
think that mushroom might add a little
something more in it than just what I
saw do not smash that
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry for - Joel oh
shoot - Liz a big dumb idiot I'm so
sorry about that
also did you know that you have many
moles living inside of you a very this
different card goodbye I find then
goodbye
okay I'm sorry okay how did I get that
back are you finally tired
those are aliens Burke honestly I
wouldn't be able to tell aliens any
apart from any other species those
around here so I guess that's a horrible
I hate that is
oh okay that's not okay
I don't even know if we're on earth but
I don't think you can just claim it as
your own birthday I mean can you be come
on TV
Danny yeah TV very entertaining oh yes
[Music]
[ __ ] come on that was very expensive
TV all right how about music I can play
music early I can you may know this song
is Wonderwall it's a it's a masterpiece
in my home country huh
you like it okay everybody's a critic
all right um I don't know what that's
about and I don't know what the cat is
but I'm gonna go with this one
okay I don't think he has eyeballs sighs
okay
yeah doesn't have eyeballs so I didn't
think that that was actually gonna work
on him so okay all right how about the
cat yes it's so cute
don't zap it please don't that that's
not good you're gonna get zapped okay
goodbye all so that was the first like
normal creature that we've seen in this
entire game so I'm not a Harbison sure
why there was a cat angry face
shockingly this seems to be working okay
okay easy enough goodbye then
thanks for visiting see you around I
suppose yeah you're pretty good to chill
yeah you did it congratulations yeah but
no okay I'm very buff and strong okay
all right then hmm hammer I do like a
good hammer hammer time maybe no that
didn't seem to okay yep as always
Tootles plans in dark for me
nice stabbim shankam I created this ship
okay that is not a knife that is
absolutely that was it you know
Chucho I gotta admit that is incredibly
violent if that wasn't a gaseous cloud
you would have just straight up murdered
someone that is incredibly horrifying
okay all right then well that didn't
work how about Godzilla maybe like a
good Godzilla anybody
loose man know why always me you [ __ ]
all right fine then I'm down to my last
straw I'm gonna smile at you real hard
like I know I'm so dice right boy what
are the odds that for well okay we have
a little bit of time what are the odds
that three different alien races we're
gonna visit us today
Bob oh wow that's a problem okay I'm
dead perrolli dad okay
[Laughter]
babar Blaine all right goodbye
boom rang rang of boom I got time-lock
okay well how about another arrow no
words stuck here all right again
very very clever very clever you almost
had me man you did have me so very very
clever Oh a stick was that way I thought
it wasn't oh it's all in my control now
oh good oh you bastard it is okay that's
dead bird all right how about whoa all
right that's that's not good all righty
then straight up now you're gonna get it
that's right this three buckets up there
now in addition to other aliens that
there are Lebowski oh yeah you didn't
like that it's grandma's piano
ah I don't even know what that is that
steamboat okay see ya bye
oh you think I'm the cloud do you I know
exactly what cloud you're in mr. okay
it's like a flak cannon up in here ah
Bostick okay never mind them ha that
dad's bizarre nope ok alright
it goes white flick it go how about oh
oh it's raining cats and dogs that's
hilarious
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry for everything
I've ever done I'm sorry
I'm very sorry well I'm bone okay
alright we're fine how about dick okay
that doesn't make okay and he's dead now
alright Emma
I got you I so got you do you have boobs
and nipples yep yeah you have boobs and
nipples I'm sorry about that
very sorry that's not what I thought you
needed to cover up okay all right then
[Music]
it's that guy again but what is that
gonna do for me okay well I've already
seen all this stuff how about this tiny
tiny cloud right there well there we go
there we go there we go well there we go
there we go now I got it now you can't
escape from my ride
easy peasy oh okay all right all right
oh you're a wily one how did you get up
into space that doesn't even make any
sense
a balloon wouldn't take you that high
it's illogical it's against science come
on all right
well I miss hey baby
[Music]
okay well that's oh I thought I was
gonna get it right then in there I'm Way
off hey gotcha baby my name isn't that
bad my dude what the hell you think I
can't spit my way through the moon also
freakin bad if twice why was that glob
white I am obviously the one that didn't
think this through it's not the entirety
of this scenario is completely illogical
no I'm the one that made a mistake by
spitting a white glob of glue up to the
moon and in the end I shove my cherry
sir you can shut up and suck it I am
obviously the best water yo go away
please and all like you I don't want to
poke it I died I don't wanna poke it I
just don't want to poke it all right
fine whatever okay and I completely
abandoned my cherry that I have been
fighting over planets for all right sure
that man that's a logical noise for a
ladybug to make otherwise their blood on
it
this seems to be a little bit of a lot
on it again okay that's why there's
blood on it that's problem can you die
okay thank you
I really needed that arm please oh I'm
still gonna be poking it okay yeah even
though I lost an arm and a horribly
painful exchange to chill very dead to
chill extremely dead shushil superdad
[Music]
okay so gonna censor your mouth even
though the very last man Jesus stuff I
mean if you have to live in this world I
suppose you have to be tough enough to
be able to survive anything
why does that frog have nipple eyes you
know that's horrible or does they have
two mouths I don't know what it has but
I don't like that and why is there a
giant gaping butthole in the sky I just
noticed dog-rose makes very little sense
somewhere noxious fart clouds all over
the place jar anyone okay what do you
got alright terrifying cool great yeah
okay all right of course
okay this is a constant companion that
I'm gonna be handling thank you I mean
it's gonna go in order of size even
though I totally just broke the order of
size okay that was my first
that's horrible I don't know I don't
even want to know where that came out of
all right you next okay I just picked
you up to exercise I suppose nope right
okay
there's no point in I get it are you
talking to me about this because I
already know what needs to be happening
over here no that's horrible
oh that's your mouth on top I never
would have guessed that ever in the
history of forever I never would have
guessed that well that is in definitely
a thing that is freakin disgusting but
now that that is a thing what do there's
a specific order that needs to happen
here I understand this you do that and
then you then you okay good you maybe
you go on the small side and what good
is that gonna do anybody I have
absolutely no idea I'm sorry
well that didn't help me at all but how
does that help me
I want to be helped maybe ah maybe I
have to go wait no that's not it I know
what I need to do I know what I need to
do this puzzle is very tricky okay here
we go now Mahbub
and boy I knew what I was doing the
whole time I didn't even look at the
goddamn clue because I'm so smart it's a
fever dream I'm dying inside hello bird
how are you doing
Hans you got damn adorable no you can't
run from me no I will hunt you until the
ends of the earth that will find you and
I will kill you I have a very particular
set of skills sleep sleep sleep oh okay
well I think my objective has been
accomplished excuse me while I rummage
around in your crotch well oh no I found
your baby just like the paw all right
well then I'm very sorry about this I'm
sorry
also Churchill is an incredible pain and
if you could stop that I'd be very happy
I hate it already okay cool
all right thanks I hate it yeah Oh
awesome this is the worst thing all
right this is great except that is zero
okay yeah okay what about that what are
you pointing towards what are you
pointing towards you big dumb goof I
know what you need but you don't need
that right now you need to
also I don't like how disgusting this
soap dispenser is okay hello
no all right a little mr. tooth man
okay don't know how a man's to do that
but apparently I did dive no I just said
dive well alright then that's how you
know when you've got an arrow going like
that I assumed that you meant dive for
when I was up there oh hey that's that's
actually incredibly handy hello oh it's
a monster okay all right that makes
sense
ow alrighty then
so what I need to do is I need to get
away from you well we're gonna make this
a team effort
alright how about we land on this thing
oh come on
well that didn't help anybody I'm really
sad that I did it right about this
there we go that's the good stuff good
mouth no I know but no why would you
lick that was it at the point of that
all right whatever I got this Stosh
alright okay alright well then that's
awfully peculiar hello
I don't know about them well that's not
good hello snake how are you doing I
don't know I just birth doing okay
that's why why would you why why would
you do that why would you just eat a
part of the scale okay I don't
understand anything that just happened
there look what happens if I just create
a whole bunch of you [ __ ] what are
you gonna do with your life there a
limit oh no you're out I'm sorry I've
empty do you have Oh
what the hell is happening oh there we
go
yeah nope no I don't understand how the
physics of that works but okay you
persevered and you didn't do anything so
I guess you're just completely boned no
no it is not gonna happen okay and now
we got something I don't even know how
you're heading on with your feet okay
where are you going buddy
wow you are incredibly strong that is a
booger oh that's
the most thing I don't see with my life
yeah that is something pretty horrible
okay all right I'm very unhappy about
that so what is that gonna do for me
then tell me of anything over here
scooby-doo okay all right then Oh what
good did bad you just go for it man just
go for it come on he's not gonna notice
oh you noticed seems to be a bit of a
problem
[Music]
chuja I didn't know that you can move so
fast
I have activity back oh I've got it I
gotta climb the booger down Hey
oh-ho-ho I got ya I got you and there's
not a thing you can do choppers what are
you gonna do just wallow in anger
choppers you get out of here oh yeah
yeah I'll be sad a roadway oh oh that's
not good okay I didn't know you had
friends me to chill I don't have any
friends so I kind of operate solo the
whole time
what is that also why is there a dead
doll in the corner over there I'll push
it why not every time I see a button I
gotta push it so that doesn't seem right
[Music]
yeah some to scream for what's about to
get quick who knows okay that's bizarre
am i centaur okay all right then that's
I don't understand how we got underwater
but okay I like this reality this is
good reality I like that one that's good
Oh
what oh I suddenly just got like a chill
down my spine this would be a crazy time
for this game to suddenly turn into a
horror game ah I see all bad all bad
hundred percent okay well there's
nothing else I can do I'll just go and
push the button man Oh
plunk ah ee bad what's worse than death
- alright oh oh oh ah you know it keeps
getting worse what am I gonna to chose
dad to do that forever oh thank you
thank you for laughing at my expense
that's wonderful from this what are you
gonna do to me what kind of horrible
experimenter you're gonna be subjecting
me to and why why do I have a bad
feeling in the base of my spine about it
I feel you're a drown one of us and make
the other watch or drown both of us at
the zero okay well I've always been told
to take the red pill here we go shove it
right in my gob alrighty okay ah blue
pill for you why not ah yes
this is horrible you know I I suspected
that there was gonna be horrible
monstrous consequences but alas it seems
like that's not the case
sure okay all right then dad it's
horrible ah you exploded or I'll give
you happy address and I'll give you
sadness you be sad oh oh you're angry I
thought you were gonna be sad that's a
bad end
oh okay
I see I see I see so we're trying to get
a rational answer here okay I don't know
how we're gonna be doing that but all
right oh that one has one eye
ah so the red pill gives one eye they
both give them if I'm not sure which
which you need a wolf at Liz the same
pattern I'm going back up and I'm gonna
try we're gonna try this okay close but
not what we wanted give you angry
[Music]
because I'll give you angry
nope that didn't work out all right well
whatever oh wait we're closed hey hey
we're closed ah I think we got it all
right you're gonna be unhappy and you're
gonna be unhappy and then we got what we
needed to go tell ya oh you both very
unhappy other science experiment went
gray I'm very excited about this oh you
guys suck hey you got out all you had to
do is throw up the pill and you're fine
apparently for some reason that's how
science works are we really gonna
confront this bastard
hey you giant hand in the sky can you
finally fess up to being a giant brick
yeah come on you've been messing around
too much here oh I see how it's gonna be
huh well I wouldn't jump Oh
oh that's adorable
oh you job okay yeah I feel the same way
dude okay I don't even know what you're
doing oh this is so cute this is
[Music]
oh all right
I don't know how to do this one go easy
enough shoo bonkers hello how are you
doing why am i skating now on this
little big thing well I don't even know
what this thing is is it fairly there
are dogs is hi hello Fairlie there are
dogs and cats in this world but not a
hundred percent sure about everything
else
hello okay goodbye oh okay I see
surprised accountants over here okay I
feel like we might be approaching the
end of the game this feels out awfully
like climatic to the end of the Thiemann
and I guess the theme would be just
utter and total chaos and music but
isn't that like the magic of the whole
thing is of your
alright but this is not the magic of
this game kind of like a random grab bag
of different monstrosity and different
like animation styles and different
things to be done hey come on don't we
deserve it
doesn't chew chill deserve it come on
give it up to chill please your
beggining be nice oh oh you're like
choo-choos older much more disgusting
brother Chu Chu can you shut up for one
second choo choo choo choo
oh shoot it broke hey come on big choo
choo you broke him
I gotta be such a douche oh oh oh well
now you gonna get it I guess
well that's gotta be disgusting oh no oh
no oh no this is awful
I don't want to be here okay well we are
here now okay all right okay these teeth
are supposed to work but something tells
me brushing ain't gonna fix it trying
I'm trying I'm trying okay Oh God why do
you have teeth back here how far in the
mouth do you have teeth Oh
okay I hate it okay nevermind I hate
everything about this is the worst thing
in the world
okay I guess we're gonna fight oh yeah
that's right you want to mess with
choo-choo Bob yeah we keep you out here
get out here
Jesus got fists of fury baby oh never
get your juju I got the double jab Wow
yeah that's right you better back off
the truth - I'm too strong I'm three
strong you ain't gonna never get close
to me oh well I can at least say I'm
stronger than my Big Brother's teeth and
that's all the matters in life uncle
Oh cuckoo boo boo boo boo boo boo good
job there oh hi that's not good okay
that doesn't make any sense at all why
are your teeth sentient in your body
that makes no sense okay
[Music]
yeah to draw few samurai okay horrible
horrible horrible yeah you shouldn't
feel too good about that okay all right
which way do I go
oh it's boozled okay well ah whoo all
right I got I think I got the answer oh
[Music]
[Music]
you know this whole game I've been
questioning the sanity of this and yet
for some reason this part just seems
totally normal to me and I and I don't
know why it does but it just kind of
does you know like if there was any
sense of normally normalcy to be gleaned
from this experience that I am currently
enduring it's that you can get used to
anything that is not the most bizarre
thing that I've ever experienced oh oh I
want to go to the but oh i 100% want to
go to the but oh you know you know I
have to go to the but oh I have to go to
that sweet-ass is this the time hang on
with this one I guess
what is happening okay oh please please
sensei I must learn to retrieve my love
question mark I have no idea oh boy ah
yes the final the final journey of true
Cheol you don't screw it up now buddy
[Music]
okay well that didn't work out too good
for me
all that training all those years for
nothing all right how about love please
love it's about love man
I pulled the head out of my own chest my
heart my true beating heart please
[Music]
all right well you're a bit of a dick
aren't you you want fine then hello this
I saw this and Zuk Zuk good good good
[Music]
leading profusely from the face wait
that's not fair well that's hardly fair
I tried real hard though
snail how about that oh I don't know how
to make this go I got double-click of
them go go go okay go go go go
wait that that oh oh I see oh I see leg
all right that makes very little sense
okay not a hundred percent sure about
this we're gonna try this move good luck
keep going keep going keep going you got
this God what more rocket blasts oh
[Music]
that's not good well [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm not sure that how the game goes but
whatever you say man I'll challenge you
to chess come on we got oh this is
actually Jess oh I am not good at chess
oh no no no okay good all right Lise I
don't have to play chess I am not good
at chess all right how about a cannon
ball this way all righty then that
doesn't make much sense okay that didn't
help it on how about a cannibal this way
let's see that doesn't seem fair when
you can just use those alrighty then
and I got to remember that I'm still
fantasizing this in the bowels of my own
brother before I get head towards the
butt and I am gonna head towards a
little bit yeah Oh what is this
uh-huh uh-huh right I got that that
doesn't make any sense at all that don't
understand that watch these big muscles
right here buddy yeah yeah you want some
of this oh here comes my own death and
I'm dead these minigames don't actually
work I may yell at you then it's all I
have do you like that okay baby
you know what I'm done with this I don't
need that cherry that badly I give up
no I'm playing your stupid games [ __ ]
you take the suit sharing shove it up
your ass
yeah cry-baby [ __ ] Oh doh you were
crying before and now you're gonna be
stuck there forever oh never mind you're
gonna be dead it's true love everybody
shut up it's love okay oh hello thank
you yes we made it live through the
bowels of my brother and now I get to go
to the bots I hope this is the but
that's the only thing that could I
possibly imagine I know this is the crux
this is the most important decision of
the entire game go to the but of course
you go to the point okay maybe if we
weren't supposed to go to the bud all
right fine then Wow
geez criticize me much
what's wrong with going to the boy I was
all about going that doesn't make any
sense okay that's I feel and this ladies
and gentlemen is all it takes to cure
depression there you go
depression over nope that broke okay so
all we gotta do is get a little hair
ball to go inside of us touch our butt
and then fuddle with our brain switch
hello yeah me too
whatever you said it oh that was such an
adventure and then we learn to share oh
[Music]
goodness gracious I don't even know if
you're a mouse you're a rat I don't even
know if you have a name I don't even
know if I want to give you a name that
means I have to take you well no that's
happening now all right well okay all
right I guess I'll call you call you
piece of [ __ ] that's what I'll call you
guys that's good enough for me come from
oh that's right I live beneath the
cherry trees
Evon that's right okay it is like Donkey
Kong at the end of it I have a horde of
cherries oh you're so nice big brother
oh that's so nice oh I guess I can call
the rat Peter the prick because he was
kind of an [ __ ] the entire time Oh oh
no is everything relative everything is
relative everything is relative but that
was beautiful yeah that was Chucho that
was so delightful that was so delightful
my goodness did one person do all of
that animation because if they did that
is just astonishing well done everybody
that worked on this game this game is a
goddamn delight 100 percent through and
through this game was a goddamn delight
the brick anyway this uh this game was
just pure and simple lovely and I am so
happy that I was able to play it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below hope you enjoyed this one
I'll leave a link in the description for
the game and if you like this please
support the game on Steam thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know you thought down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video buh-bye